um so i want to start what i think with
the most important question uh cara uh
it's for you um i'm kamina has such a
unique look that i am curious if you've
ever wanted or if you ever did leave set
with full makeup the tattoos and
everything go to starbucks or a store
and be like oh i get treated a lot
different in makeup
[Laughter]
you know what i've never done it i've
never wandered around town as drummer
i missed my chance
do you know what i
i feel like i'm just so eager to take it
off to be honest it's so um
it's so drummer it's so intense and to
part of you know getting
leaving the day behind the ritual of
taking that makeup off is uh
you know
it's an important part of leaving it all
behind
to be honest
no completely i have some friends who
act who've explained that to me as well
i just still you know it's it i would
imagine you'd be treated a lot different
with that
you know what i mean neck tattoo big
neck
for sure for sure she definitely she
definitely wields those glares when she
needs it for the record oh yeah i can do
the glares like even without the makeup
or the yeah yeah
she's chastised me several times already
today
i i heard from the casting director
that's how she got the role yeah yeah
exactly
um so uh obviously i'm very thankful to
amazon for saving the series um and
keeping it on the air and giving it this
great last season um and i am curious
for the both of you do you feel like
when you need to buy something nowadays
you sort of have to buy it on amazon
no
no that feels like it feels like i'm
like taking a bite out of my paycheck
if anything i'm like oh i gotta get this
somewhere else because i otherwise it's
like what have i done work for nothing
uh being serious now um the thing about
the expanse is like me uh the fans of
the series are very passionate very
engaged very much following things what
do you think it is about the the series
and the story that has you know
captivated so many people
oh
do you know what i think is one of the
the greatest things about this show is
that it doesn't um
it doesn't dumb itself down in any way
shape or form it's not a show you can
have on in the background i think that
it is it it assumes the very best of its
audience and i think people respond to
that you know we don't have to over
explain things or like
you know explain this with a flashback
like i think it i think naren especially
um as well as of course all of the
writers but i think we do a really good
job of um
respecting our audience's intelligence
and not
and as a part of that not
giving any clear-cut black-and-white
answers yeah yeah i think that
and it's even true about marco i mean
nothing is is good or evil
there's a full spectrum and everyone is
making choices along that spectrum and
may make choices along different parts
of that spectrum
and
i i wish we could see more of that on on
television actually yeah yeah
the thing about marco is that he makes
excellent points the things that he's
fighting for
you absolutely side with him i think he
maybe just goes a slight bit too far um
with you know what he's trying to uh
what he does so what is it like what's
your take on marco in terms of you know
i i guess you know what i mean how do
you feel about him
playing him
i i feel like
seeing what he's seen
and having experienced what he's
experienced
i can't imagine
if he had the bandwidth and if he had
the capacity and the drive
to do whatever it took to make it
different i don't see why he wouldn't i
i mean
if somebody didn't have the bandwidth if
somebody didn't have the the capacity if
somebody didn't have the intelligence if
somebody didn't have the drive to do it
i understand fully you just resign
yourself to your life and and perhaps
you you give up a little bit or you
shrink in order to make it feel okay but
there is nothing about him that's
shrunken
there is there is nothing about him that
is willing to play small
quite to the contrary he insists on
being larger than life and sees him
larger than life and i think there's
something
really noble about that he there is huge
sacrifice that he's willing to make
in order
to to make that a reality and
being a young
single father was a huge part of that
like
he
like the the experience of having a life
depend on you and to the experience of
knowing what you went through and from
the bottom of your heart
never wanting your son to have that same
experience is a lot of pressure it's a
lot of pressure to say hey i don't know
how many more years i have in this life
but if i don't make this situation
better for my children i don't know what
my life is worth and that's the degree
of his
um uh
uh
feeling his urgency is that it has to
happen for my kid or my kid is going to
suffer in the same way that i did
and i understand that i can empathize
with that i i can empathize with any
human being who is suffering and does
not want their child to suffer the same
and is willing to
make an uproar in some way to make that
happen even if it means
that they have to do things that may
feel abhorrent you know like i
understand that desperation i'm not
condoning it but i understand it and i
and i respect that
parental love that leads to that
um i've seen the entire final season and
uh
it's fantastic um but i don't know how
much you guys are allowed to say so what
are you allowed to tease to the fans of
about the final season
just like go to the very limit please
what you can say um i mean i think that
i think that
the fact that drummer is
still alive is pretty remarkable i think
things seem pretty hopeless for her um
so anything really on top of that is
just kind of gravy for her
i think um
i think it's a really satisfying ending
um without any spoilers i feel like it's
it it answers enough questions and it
leaves enough questions unanswered to be
i think extremely extremely satisfying
for the audience who's been with us for
this whole ride
and i will say i agree with that i think
they've synthesized the final season
and jam-packed it in
a really masterful way
and i will also say
you can you see behind the multiple
facades of marco
this season for the first time as the
cracks in his psychology become apparent
and um
you may see you know you may see parts
of him that you you didn't know
existed and that's kind of cool well i'm
curious for both of you you really don't
know how much you're going to be
featured in a season until you get the
scripts both of you have really juicy
parts this season with a lot to do what
was it like reading those scripts for
the first time and being like oh this is
really good
yeah it's pretty funny i was definitely
hired um back in season two uh on a
guest star
role so for me i'm just like this is
nuts like what am i doing on the poster
now this is just crazy that this went
this way um
you're so cute when you're humble
[Laughter]
knows it's just pretend
she walked around set calling herself
the queen of the universe it was um less
humble
um
but for the cameras i
shouldn't do it
um
this is the problem getting paired with
a friend to do this interview because i
can't get away with anything um okay go
back to being sweet okay okay okay okay
okay okay
um
go back to being sweet
yeah i mean they're dream scripts
they're dreams it's like christmas
morning you get a script and it's like
holy [ __ ] i get to do this it's gonna be
incredible like
it's
i get to do it with this person i get to
do this scene i get to you know it's
like yeah it blows your mind really it's
exciting especially for marco especially
when
he gets to see the speeches yeah on the
page there's like something there's like
the marco in me just like oh yes they
get i get to hear my voice they get to
hear my voice
it's uh it's like feeling feeling like
the work the words
have an aliveness to them and can't help
but just like well up in you it's it's
so well written and so perfect for the
character that that that was definitely
exciting because you don't i don't know
what those are going to look like i
don't know what his big
orations will will materialize
like but
that's exciting for sure oh yeah to see
his opportunities to to like be on
display
what was it like i am curious for each
of you the last day of filming and did
you notice in the days leading up to
that last day that you were possibly
borrowing a few extra things here and
there from set and taking them home
i didn't take anything home that's just
like i i just drummer's so like i just
want to leave her be her life is so
different from mine and i don't i just
i'm not
i don't yeah i didn't take anything um
but definitely i actually shot the very
very last scene of the last
day
um that was me and my my crew
uh sammer salem and vanessa smythe who i
loved so dearly um
and uh
i mean it was kind of surreal to be
honest like
everybody they had the big a big screen
set up so all of our producer friends
and writer friends could zoom in and
we're like hey
[Music]
we did it
um
but yeah it was really weird it's it's
like really nice to all be together to
do press
now because i feel like we didn't have
that chance at the time
you know to it was like pre-vaccine
depths of the pandemic so we were all
pretty isolated then
for you
ah yeah it was it was a trip we
a bunch of you guys
from my last day showed up
i think i had a speech
it
you think you think he understands i
mean marco did a speech and then key on
this yeah so there's a lot of
speechifying but it was sweet i mean
having having them around for the last
day it was definitely it's been a
strange experience sort of like
disentangling from that guy that that's
that's definitely a trip
um have you been hunted
but i did take uh this is probably not
supporting my disentangling process but
i did take his amazing
belt buckle that i that i jammed with
our wardrobe designer joanne hansen to
design with specific geometry and and a
lot of beautiful specifics on there so
they gifted that to me so i'm pretty
happy to still have that and i sleep
with it for sure
when i'm having marco dreams
that's intense yeah
pretty juicy
for both of you um i would imagine
getting to portray these characters is
going to be something that you take with
you the rest of your life um what do you
think you're going to miss most about
actually inhabiting these roles
it's such a rare treat
as an artist to be given a script that
um
sometimes you get it and it's like holy
[ __ ] how am i gonna do this like the
script challenges us to rise to the
occasion you know sometimes you
i don't know especially like our main
job is auditioning and you get auditions
and you're like this is such garbage
and you have to like try to find ways to
like make it believable almost you know
what i mean uh which is the exact
opposite of this experience where you're
like oh my god i have to inhabit this
and so to be challenged in that way um
it's incredible it's an incredible
experience so that's what i'll miss the
most about playing drummer for sure
and there's a word that marco uses that
really like
he is still rippling within me which is
you must be audacious
and i think there's something really
[Music]
like if i knew that i only had a certain
number of days or months to live
i think immediately
my audacity
would increase i think i would take
risks and put myself out there in a lot
of ways and i think that's
i i i honor and i value his
his audacity
like for better for worse he's putting
himself out there and he's making those
big choices and he's literally
lunging himself pelvis first towards his
vision
um
i would imagine that this show um
actually i'm going to switch my life
there's a different question i think
there's a lot of people behind the
scenes that don't get recognized for
their contributions to the expanse and
everything you know that to make this
series so maybe for each of you who's
like an unsung hero that you want to
give like a shout out to and like just
thank them for their work
oh my god well verity who does my makeup
fiction and my makeup
yeah that's true she's rad she's just
like
such a boss um
like keep an eye out for her i feel like
she's gonna become a producer
extraordinaire and like take over the
world she's um
she's she's worked on several several
incredible projects and she's yeah just
a
real bombshell of a human super smart
super funny
super talented amy in production offices
amy amy was holding this shift together
in a lot of ways yes
she's amazing she's amazing um behind
the scenes lou and webb oh yeah luin was
there with us every day always had our
back yeah one of the producers i would
say jason vieira our um our steadicam
operator is like
just a dream of a human being super
talented he's like responsible for so
much of that zero g feeling and like
really be like
like almost straddled the line between
being cast and crew because there's he
danced with us right like it was like
choreography we were doing with him oh
yeah and we had like a language together
yeah with the support of the amazing
cinematographer jeremy yeah i mean
jeremy he's amazing who is amazing but
there's one there's a scene i can't wait
for everyone to see it but in in episode
six where
jason
did something
that i've never seen done before i saw
him move in like a gymnastic way that
i've never seen and he found some magic
with me it was he was literally my dance
partner in this long scene in episode
six that is just magic like there's so
many people to answer your question
there's so many people who have invested
like heart soul
into this to make this magic and it is
truly it may not be the case in every
instance but this is truly
like a group undertaking this is truly
like a
a communal effort that required
investment above and beyond what's
required of you at the level of your job
it's it's like
pouring your soul into creating this
this creative enterprise and this is one
of those rare ones where that magic
comes from everyone's investment every
department everything yeah i mean i mean
yeah it's to say nothing
we can't list everyone yeah like we're
like doing the credits basically like
the whole props team like the vfx team
yeah like sets lighting yeah
no i think i think that a lot of people
they see what's in on the screen but i i
don't think a lot of people realize the
amount of people behind the scenes like
it's one thing to look at the credits
but unless you've stood there on set to
see what it really takes i just think a
lot of people don't realize how
how many people are bringing this to
life how many people it took to help us
just get our suits on yeah yeah not not
a joke like multiple people helping it's
it's i'm telling you it's a team effort
yeah yeah um i i basically have to stop
but i'm just gonna
yeah i think i can sneak in one more uh
i was just curious if you could talk
about if you could keep one of the sets
that you've worked on or been on which
one would you want to keep in like your
backyard the pella the pella is the most
amazing spaceship i've ever seen it's
better than all the other ones and it
has two floors and it's beautiful the
office of the behemoth with the
brokeback cowboys in the background
i like both of those answers listen
thank you so much for your work yeah
have a great day
you